now accepting his re-election in his
speech Jeremy Corbyn promised to launch
a national campaign against the
government's plans to bring back grammar
schools now that comes after the Labour
leader of course quarter rare victory
against Theresa majoring Prime
Minister's Questions the other week and
in doing so managed to unite the type of
party behind him on that issue well the
cabinet minister and chairman of the
Conservative Party said Patrick
McLoughlin joins me now very good
morning to you sir patrick well let's
start then ahead of your conference next
week with the issue of of grammar
schools hasn't it given the Labour Party
a stick to beat you with and to unite
itself well I don't accept that at all
we published a green paper on what we
want to do for the future of Education
this means concentrating on those
schools routing very well so academies
you have sports academies you have music
academies I think it is right that as
Justine Greening has said but we need to
look at academic achievement to and give
people the opportunity to attend those
schools yeah but haven't you yourself
said in the past in a lot of people now
saying it Jeremy Corbyn said it in the
house of commons at that Prime
Minister's Questions what you used to
support it seems was good schools in all
areas for all people yes and that's
exactly what this program is at the
moment to even when the last Labour
Party were in government there were
grammar schools in certain parts of the
country and I year I don't see why they
should be in certain parts of the
country and not available in other parts
of the country and that's exactly one of
the things the threesum a and Justin
green greening wants us to to put right
well as I said so one of the issues that
seems to have got many members of Labour
Party behind Jeremy Corbyn of course he
was reelected again with an increased
majority as you well know are you one of
those people in spite of the fact of
your loyalty to the Conservative Party
they're almost regrets that the Labour
Party is so divided so split and so
apparently week that you need a strong
opposition in this country well look the
Labour Party's got to look after itself
I'm the simple fact is you've got the
position now where the labor force
you've got a leader where
172 of his own MPs didn't think that he
was fit to lead the labour party let
alone fits around the country but while
we're in government we've got the
responsibility of pursuing the people's
wishes as far as the referendum is
concerned that's what we're doing and
also addressing issues right across the
Sierra government so be it in the health
service be it in education be it in
international development and we will
share over the next three and a half
years why it's so important to reelect a
Conservative government it's interesting
there isn't it sir patrick as we're here
discussing divisions within the Labour
Party we find today just how deep the
divisions in the Conservative Party were
and are over that EU referendum and this
some referring to the book by sir Craig
Oliver who you know very well who round
the referendum campaigners at the Prime
Minister's side as press secretary for
many years the former Prime Minister
side i should say and this issue of
theresa may not really batting for
remain she let down Mr Cameron that's
the allegation well I don't think that's
true at all I mean the simple fact is
this is being written after the events
Theresa May during the referendum
campaign made her position very clear
and made sir public pronouncements and
indeed public speeches but there were
lots of people in the referendum
campaign be it from the the Chancellor
then foreign secretary to the leader of
the Opposition or leader of the Liberal
Party there was a number of people that
were making the case to remain but at
the end of the day the British people
decided that we should leave and now
it's the job of Theresa May and the
people around in the cabinet to deliver
on that on that result but did you
really think at the time sir patrick
that she was pulling her weight
according to sir craig they referred to
a mr. cameron and others refer to as the
submarine Theresa May was below the
surface not well which is there really
is a broader name well this is a book
that's been written after the event and
no doubt their interpretations after the
event you know you've got to say you go
have certain spicy things in the book to
sell it I don't blame her Craig for
doing for doing that but at the time
Theresa was a
very much part of the remain campaign
but she has rightly said the British
people have come to a decision and we've
got to carry out now the results of the
referendum which is to leave the
European Union okay right but that is we
no brakes it means brexit but so we've
been hearing from the former Chancellor
hammer we about what kind of breaks it
and it's been turned soft or hard where
do you stand on that the hard brexit
been we we get out come what may and if
that means then no membership or no
access to the single market Soviet well
let's wait and see that I realize this
is frustrating because we're not going
to give a running commentary on exactly
where we are with the negotiations part
of the negotiations if we were through
air them live or keep giving running
commentaries that would reduce a
negotiating position as we enter into
those negotiations so I know that on
programs like this and and other
programs we're going to be pressed to
get more information I'm afraid we're
going to have to resist the temptation
as to ever i'm hard brexit soft brexit
medium brexit what we are is leaving the
European Union but trying to get the
best deal obviously for the United
Kingdom but also the the rest of Europe
asteroid acknowledged to they sell goods
to us as well as us selling goods to
them let me put another formulation and
nuanced brexit sir george osborne's
description of the voters fairly close
so therefore even all those in the
brexit camp won't let's save the UK
persuasion for instance well look the
simple fact is as george i'm sure we'll
have acknowledged the referendum was
decisive it was very clearly that we
should leave the European Union and
we'll have those negotiations and George
will report that debate i mean george
will be exercising his his views as a
backbench member of parliament which is
more than capable of doing trying to
influence that debate but we can't in
government give a running commentary on
exactly where we are on every aspect of
the issues as they go through but what
do you think about george osborne's
visibility can
head without of his former boss David
Cameron the two commanding figures of
the party over the last decade do you
think George Osborne's should be more
like mr. Cameron and a period of
prolonged period of silence would be
more appropriate I don't George wants to
contribute to the debate George has said
that he's staying actively in the House
of Commons and I very much welcome that
he did a fantastic job as Chancellor and
he's taking a bit of time now to see
what what else is going on as far as
David Cameron's concerned that saw David
in the week and he accepts at his time
at the top of politics is over and he's
thinking about what he wants to do